[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i was watching the eagles game against
the cardinals
and i was enjoying the commentary by
akeeb talib the fox sports analyst
five-time pro bowler won a super bowl
with the broncos
and now working for fox and uh keeb
talib joining us on the program
how would you rate your performance so
far akib
i don't have to rate it then i and you
know i just
i just go out and uh try to have a
little fun so
you know i got pretty good feedback i
read it off the feedback so
you know i got pretty good feedback uh
from the guys
over at fox so i bet i guess it was
decent
but also it's really important to get
people who are gonna be honest with you
because a lot of people just say hey man
sounded good
and if they say that then say well what
did you like like you gotta
if you really want to know if if you
approach this the way you did as a
defensive back
hey i want to be great how do i be great
you have to
approach it the same way and hopefully
you got some people who won't just go
yep that was good man i enjoyed it ask
them or
was there anything that i you didn't
like because if you if you do ask those
questions
you might get some answers that can
really help you
right right that's and i do i do that
rich
man damn i'm sorry i do that uh i i got
some people on my team who
brutally honest so i think uh from week
one
from the first game to the second game i
think i improved and i think
it had a lot to do with uh the the
criticism that i received from people
who i asked
but also you're looking at this from a
defensive perspective or at least i get
that feeling
a lot of analysts are offensive you know
players former quarterbacks
are you purposely looking at it from a
different perspective because you played
defensive back
well i i think i look at it i just watch
the game and talk about it
as i see it so naturally i see it as a
defensive person a defensive
perspective so i think i call the game
that way so i think
i think that just comes naturally and
then you start to uh
break things down like it's weird to
watch a game
that way are you watching off the
monitor are you watching
the actual game itself well i watch i
watch the actual game itself
so i watch uh i just watch and see what
coverage stay in
once the play starts i see what coverage
to him my eyes kind of move to
the quarterback and i see where he throw
the ball at and i i know
kind of what he's throwing the ball into
you know
because i know what coverage stands so i
always start with the defense see what
they plan first and then
my eyes move to the offense but i'm
watching the game off the field itself
and i love that you just tell it as it
is that i feel like i'm watching
a game with a former player but not a
former player who went
to broadcast school you're just saying
hey this is what i see
and this is what i'm saying and and it's
refreshing
and i and i hope you're able to still be
yourself because a lot of times
the executives come in or producers or
directors and then they want to change
you a little bit
i i like that it's it's not polished but
i didn't expect it to be because you're
still
you're starting out and trying to figure
all this out but it feels honest to keeb
that's probably
the best com compliment i can give you
it feels honest in what you're telling
me when you're breaking things down are
you
worried about being too honest in that
position
uh i'm not i'm just i go off the uh the
audition
during the pandemic i had to audition
and uh
we kind of did it over the zoom call we
caught a game me and uh kevin burkhart
caught a game over zoom
and i just i however i called the game
on there
it was good enough for me to sign a
three game
deal with fox no good so you know
uh if it was good enough to do that then
it was
it was good enough to give me a second
game you know so i
i only know one way to do it you know
what i'm saying dan i don't i don't know
how to
not be myself an executive heaven came
in and told me to not be myself and not
be honest yet so
i'm only only know one way to do it so
that's the way i'm doing it who's
picking out the game day outfits there
for you
oh i am i am i'm doing all the all the
wardrobe
i've always been a a a dresser of myself
you know but but i i have a suit lady i
have a suit lady
at the company l of a and uh she always
does a great job i kind of
give her the feel what i'm kind of going
for and she always do a great job of
bringing it to life
who would you rather face kyler murray
or jalen hurts
oh that's a tough question uh they both
so similar they bring a lot of stuff to
the table
as far as men when that pass play break
down they can turn the running backs and
they both uh throwing the ball super
good right now as well
man that's a tough question man you're
gonna have your hands full with either
one damn
yeah but you gotta pick though okay come
on you're an analyst now
i'd rather play i'd rather play i'd
rather play
[Music]
jalen hurts kyle murray he just got
another year of experience under his
belt
i think he a little further along and
there's a
in this progression right now so as of
right now today
yeah i'll take jalen hurts what was this
play against jalen hurts
what was the scouting report on
roethlisberger when you when you played
uh that he'll hold the ball
create that extra second he was in that
category with those quarterbacks
the ones that you gotta instead of two
and a half seconds we gotta guard our
receiver for three and a half seconds
because
big ben he'll shake the guy off and uh
he'll create the extra second uh what
else we had on big ben
uh he had a great deep ball if it got
covered he'd still try he with a great
deep ball
and uh that was as far as big ben not
pittsburgh
as far as big ben that was probably the
main two things that i had in my
notebook
yeah uh and then you played against and
with
brady definitely
but what is that book still accurate of
if you were facing tom now as opposed to
you know five seven years ago uh it's
different it's different it's changing a
different offense man it was a lot of
quick game a lot of
over the middle inside the numbers
scenes there was a lot of those kind of
passes now it's
the field is definitely stretching with
that bruce aaron's offense so
this is you have some adjustments just
some it's some still
vintage tom brady still in that offense
but
it's definitely a lot more a lot more
passive downfield for tom
didn't you say back in march i think
that uh brady was leaving the patriots
is that right uh i might
have i mean this that's what y'all do
y'all supposed to be able to
bring the recording up
but i definitely i had i had the feeling
it was over i remember i remember me
saying i think that the marriage is over
man it's
it's burnt out i remember saying it's
burnt out i think and i remember
predicting that uh tom was going to move
on yeah
and it's a weird thing though that just
to see him you know in tampa
um did you get yelled at by belichick
uh i did i think just about everybody
got yelled at by belichick
so yeah practice definitely definitely
in practice a few times in the game
you know bill you know he's not going to
bite his tongue so
if you in the mix if you in the game in
the mix you're probably going to get
yelled at
from them saying sooner or later he's a
keeb to lead the
fox nfl analyst five-time pro bowler won
the super bowl with the broncos super
bowl 50. this friday the vikings take on
the saints special christmas day
match-up coverage begins at 3 30 eastern
on fox
nfl network and streaming on prime video
do you have any beef
left over with somebody that you know
that's not going away even though you're
not playing anymore are you still
are you mad at anybody no no i never
really played mad at
mad at nobody i mean some somebody do
something disrespectful in the game i
usually handle it but
you know i kind of kind of leave it
leave it where it's at i don't be for
nobody in the nfl right now man
a lot more friends than enemies in nfl
who's the wide receiver that
you you lined up and you knew this can
be a long day
calvin johnson yeah i followed him
around i think three times or
two times in my career and i think i
played against him
uh maybe four times in my career
and uh every time and uh uh watching it
on tape i'm like
this guy's the best then when we got to
the game it definitely translated and he
was definitely the best in the game
who's the quarterback you loved to face
quarterback who i love to face
oh let me go back take you jason
campbell i'm gonna go back a little bit
man
i enjoyed playing against jason campbell
uh
i felt like he was on my team some of
the time
nah i definitely i definitely love you
threw me three interceptions one game
oh man i i i seen him in the lobby i
seen him in the lobby at a hotel one
time in miami super bowl
time told him he was my favorite
quarterback
[Laughter]
definitely definitely jason county oh
that is so
good wow did he think that it was a
compliment or did he know
it was a young leave super bowl time man
had a couple of guys with me my brother
was with me man he was hanging out oh
man into the room so
that is rough i think i think coming
from me he probably knew
what i was talking about well i think he
would remember he threw three pics
and uh so he could walk up to him and
he's like you're my favorite quarterback
man
yeah he knew exactly what i mean hey
well good luck with
uh you know uh the rest of the year
hopefully you got some more games in
there and uh we appreciate your time
akeeb
appreciate you thank you i'll take care
all right let's keep tally